new book shakespeare for all time he
spoke about it recently with Paul
Edmondson director of education for the
Shakespeare Birthplace trust it's one
hour we're here tonight to celebrate the
publication of a book this is the
American edition of it
it's called Shakespeare for all time the
title comes from the preparatory remarks
in the great collection of Shakespeare's
works that appeared in 1623 referred to
now as the first folio and these remarks
are by Shakespeare's rival friendly
rival I think would perhaps be the best
way to describe Ben Jonson and as he
talks about the man whose works are
being collected whose dramatic works are
being collected for the first time he
mentions that he was not of all he was
not of an age but for all time and that
really is what this book is all about if
you if you like Shakespeare if you
attend Shakespearean performances if you
see Shakespeare on film if you read
about Shakespeare the chances are very
good that you have in one way or another
encountered Stanley wells
Stanley is a member of the Board of
Governors of the Royal Shakespeare
Company he is the editor of several
versions of Shakespeare under the
imprint of Oxford University Press for
many years he was editor of Shakespeare
survey published by Cambridge University
Press he is the author of several
companion volumes to Shakespeare
published by both Oxford and Cambridge
he as the chairman of the Shakespeare
Birthplace trust in Stratford he is in
short the nearest thing that we have to
a Shakespeare monopoly
and he will be joined this evening in a
discussion of his new book by Paul
Edmondson who is director of education
at the Shakespeare Birthplace trust so
without further ado I'm delighted to
turn the program over to Paul and
Stanley thank you very much indeed John
very kind introduction you I pleased
here I hope that there is in the book in
fact a photograph of the three booth
brothers in Julius Caesar John Wilkes as
Mark Antony Edwin as Brutus and John
juniors Brutus booth junior as Cassius
and I discussed the the impact of the
assassination of Abraham Lincoln on on
boos life and also of course there's a
great deal of the book about Sir John
White a lot in the book about Sir John
Gielgud including photographs of him so
that that includes the all-time theme
put the book I think Stanley delving a
bit into your own past I mean if he
could tell us how you first became
interested in Shakespeare yeah I think
like so many people are in America I'm
sure as well as in England my interest
was first aroused by a schoolmaster a
rather brilliant schoolmaster I was born
in Hull in Yorkshire and I went to a
grammar school there's called Kingston
high school and the English teacher the
mr. EJC large was an enthusiast of
Shakespeare and he taught us in a way in
a very inspiring way he taught us to
think of the place as plays to be acted
as place to be performed he also taught
us a lot about the poetry and indeed I
think the first time I was really moved
by a work of Shakespeare was when we had
to learn by heart one of the sonnets the
sonnet beginning when in disgrace with
Fortune and men's eyes I all alone
beweep my outcast state and that spoke
to me at a time it's a poem about
friendship about love and spirit to me
in my adolescence at a time when I was
beginning to be interested in friendship
and in love and that was very inspiring
for me I was also able in those days to
see there was more touring Shakespeare
and
that tends to be nowadays it was a great
actor called sir Donald wolf it an old
barn stormer really great actor manager
and he would tour the provinces with his
company everybody in the company was
required to stand at least six feet away
from sir Donald when he was giving his
major speeches he was rather a little
tyrant and I remember him at the end of
the performance of as hello he would
come out looking as exhausted as he
possibly could and he would hang on the
curtains and say I have nothing to say
but thanks and nothing and all but
thanks and we would all applaud like
that and also a little later actually my
English teacher has had an influence on
other people too the actor Sir Thomas
Courtenay actor and film star was also a
pupil at the school where I which I
attended and pupil of mr. large is much
influenced by him sir was Malcolm's
story who is a leading actor with the
Royal Shakespeare Company and so was the
current vice vice principal of Rome the
Royal Academy of Dramatic Arts said it's
touching to me to think what an
influence a great teacher can have I was
also lucky then to go to London I had to
London University I went to the
University College London I went to
London I chose London mainly because I
knew I'd be able to see lots of
Shakespeare lots of theatre and also
hear lots of music music is a great
interest of mine and I was able for
example to see Olivier play Richard the
third on the stage I was able to see his
heavens and some you know some really
wonderful performances so what and and
had I had very good university teachers
to who inspired me about Shakespeare
so all these were ways in which I which
helped me to put to put me on my course
as a Shakespearean and and lead you to
many of your publications of course
which have dealt with a lot with
Shakespearean performance but this book
is different to all of those can you
tell us a bit about how the book is is
shaped yeah and and and what you're
trying to do with with the volume yeah
it's a book which is very much intended
to interest the intelligent general
reader some of my publications as you
know have been rather for Scotland's for
for for fellow scholars especially what
I've been doing textual
condley Oxford Shakespeare but i-i've
always I hoped been somebody who wished
to communicate with people I'm not I
don't have much to do with the the
current trend in universities studies
which tends to use rather recondite
language and you feel that scholars are
only speaking to each other I wanted to
write a book which would help to inspire
interest and inform to people who have
are acquiring an interest in Shakespeare
and in all that Shakespeare has meant
over the ages and so I designed the book
to be actually pretty comprehensive of
course you can never say everything
about Shakespeare but but the design of
the book is from then till now as it
were it has a chapter about Shakespeare
and Stratford and then all about London
that's the biographical part of the book
it then has a long chapter about
Shakespeare as a writer about how he
wrote the techniques that he adopted in
writing his plays for the stage very
much thinking about him as a writer for
the theatres in the London of his day
and then it goes into the the afterlife
for all times
very prescient of Ben Jonson to say that
a remarkable statement that he makes in
the in the poem in the first folio he
was not of an age but for all time and
that time is still of course ticking
away and Shakespeare never ceases to to
to influence as I pleased to see as I
came into the room there
Shakespeare cushions take them get away
from you and so the second part of the
book really is about the the way that
Shakespeare has permeated culture first
in England later on the continent later
still worldwide globally the way that
it's that the plays have been performed
the way that people have thought about
Shakespeare the way they've written
about him the paintings that have been
derived from Shakespeare's works as I
wrote the book I was very much in I had
very much in mind that this is was to be
an illustrated book I'd arranged with
the publishers that it would have over
150 illustrations because I don't like
the sort of book what you think picked
have been shoveled in after it was
written by a picture research you know
they seem rather irrelevant so that the
pictures have very much an integral part
of the book and so I bring the story
through the age of Davin at the age of
Garak the Romantic period the Victorians
the early 20th century up to the present
day so that's that's the overall design
of the book guising and some of the
pictures of course can't be found
elsewhere I mean they're they're only
available in your yeah I I have been
lucky enough to yes there are some
unique items which I've been able to
acquire for the book one way or another
coming back to the beginning of the book
which has two biographical chapters
about Shakespearean Stratford and then
Shakespeare in London yes one of the
things that people remarked on in
relation to Shakespeare is the fact that
he got married very early yes you Anne
Hathaway who was already three months
pregnant when he married her can you
tell us a bit about shakespeare's early
marriage to two unhappy yes it is
interesting that there is among
Shakespeare solace the 154 sonnets we
should publish towards the end of his
life there is one which is very likely
the first thing that Shakespeare wrote
or at least the first thing of
shakespeare's that that has been
published it wasn't the first to be
published but the first that is
published and can I read it - it's the
sonnet 145 it goes those lips that loves
own hands did make breathe forth the
sound that said I hate to me that
languished for her sake but when she saw
my woeful state straight in her heart
did mercy come chiding that turn that
ever sweet was used in giving gentle
doom and taught it thus and you to greet
I hate she altered with an end that
followed it as gentle day does follow
night who like a fiend from heaven to
hell is flown away
I hate from hate away she threw and
saved my life saying not you it's not a
very important time it's not very great
but i-i hate from hate away is in the
Elizabethan terms particularly a
reflection of the sound of half away and
Hathaway and this is and Shakespeare it
was author out his life he was an
inveterate punster he was always making
puns so it's very likely I think and
this was really suggested about thirty
years ago it's very like that this is
Shakespeare's first published the first
poem written by Shakespeare that that's
in print and that it's actually a love
do you think it might be by the
eighteen-year-old Shakespeare yes I do
yes in fact it sticks out like a sore
thumb in the its collection of sonnets
because it's the only one with four
beats to the line not alive yes it's an
anomaly in that point of view that's
true yes so I suspect that Shakespeare
wrote this while he was while he was
wooing the the girl whom he eventually
well the girl she was actually eight
years older than he was of course that
he eventually were not not not not very
long afterwards married because it was
clearly rather a rushed wedding that
they had the wedding has caused quite a
lot of speculation as to why what what's
the what sort of a girl he which was
that he was marrying and indeed of
course at one time people had to try to
hush up almost we books written for
children especially would sort of try to
get rounded by saying hi yes the
children would the child was born six
months after his right but in those days
you were married really by it not by
just declaring an intention to marry we
should there was some truth in that but
there's no doubt that Shakespeare was
was interested in sex from a very early
age and Anthony Burgess in his biography
of Shakespeare speculates that the
lovely boy that William probably was
auburn hair melting eyes ready tongue
tags of Latin poetry just the thing to
attract a girl had copulated with anne
hathaway he says with no talk of
betrothal a piece of wanton fornication
doubtless perpetrated in a rye field in
high summer
that he'd done this before falling in
love with somebody else called an
Wheatly sweet as may and shy as a form
and then entity Burgess speculates
Shakespeare was dragoon's into a shotgun
marriage with a woman who did whom we
did not love well that is written by a
novelist and it is entirely fictional we
have no reason to believe that
Shakespeare copulated with Anne Hathaway
in a in a wry feel that's derived from
all of his songs in hurts you like it
but yes certainly Shakespeare married
early and the-the-the-the he had a
daughter and he also had twins fairly
soon soon afterwards and they were
unfortunately sadly the boy whom we
called Hamlet which is a variant of the
name of Hamlet the boy died when he was
only 10 we don't know anything about the
details of that but this is must
admitted one must imagine that must have
been a deep emotional experience for
Shakespeare and why then did he have
sconed
to London as some people say and spend
most time away from his family well I
think the prime reason for his certainly
with the first time we hear of
Shakespeare after Stratford is in 1592
1592 when he is that twenty-eight yeah
and there's a reference to him rather
insulting reference by a writer called
Robert Greene and by that time
Shakespeare was clearly established on
the theatrical scene the reason that
Shakespeare went to London is
undoubtedly that this is where the
action was this is where the the public
theatres were this is where the
companies were based the company's one
of the prime functions of the companies
was to provide place for the
entertainment of the Queen of Queen
Elizabeth this was their their official
raison d'etre in fact and Shakespeare's
company the Lord Chamberlain's Men
frequently played at court before the
Queen and so it was very important if
you're going to to be on the theatrical
scene to be based in London Shakespeare
course was not only a writer he was also
an act
we have a number of references to it as
an act so it doesn't seem to be a
terribly good one but he said they did
act not only in his own but also in
other people's plays we know that he
acted in two players by by Ben Jonson
who was later to write the elegy for him
printed in the folio he was not only an
actor and a playwright he was also a
show he was a businessman and a very
successful businessman he was a
shareholder in the company which became
the leading company of its time was very
popular at court the queen paid for
special performances that they gave and
all this meant that he was able to buy
land and property back home in Stratford
so he didn't totally neglect his family
certainly indeed he bought before before
he was a when he was still in his 30s he
bought the second biggest house in
Stratford called new place and we
unfortunately was pulled down in the
18th century by a clergyman who got fed
up of people coming because they wanted
to see the mulberry tree that
Shakespeare was supposed to have planted
so he had the house pulled down and the
Barbra tree was chopped down and
souvenirs made out of the mulberry tree
rapidly would have needed an entire
forest of mulberry trees to have
supplied the wood for them but and it's
unfortunate I think that new place has
been it was pulled down particularly
because we have a drawing of it and the
drawing shows that he's had five Gables
and it was built around the courtyard
now for the book I had a photograph
specially taken of another building in
strips that very close by part of the
Shakespeare Hotel which also has five
Gables because I wanted to try it and I
place this juxtaposed this with the
drawing of new place because I wanted to
give people an impression more easy an
impression they can get just from just
reading about a house of this size of
how prosperous Shakespeare was how early
and that he was able to buy for his
family and we to the best of our belief
and Hathaway and Shakespeare and the
children stayed in Stratford throughout
their lives he was able to buy for them
a really rather grand establishment an
establishment which would neat have
needed a number of servants to keep up
now one of the ideas are
i propagate in the book which is an
unusual idea among scholars is that in
fact she didn't spend as much time away
from Stratford as has been generally
supposed it seems to be that if you've
got a very big very grand house your
wife and children desert and you need
books to write and I think this is an
important aspect of Shakespeare's
artistry which is not always realized
enough that Shakespeare's plays are very
closely based on other works or literary
works
some of them large books and again I had
a swish a special photograph taken to
illustrate the sort of books that shakes
me we know had in front of him as he
wrote he wasn't just inventing these
stories I did a little television
program in England not long a party
about Romeo and Juliet and somebody said
afterwards why did Shakespeare set Romeo
and Juliet in Verona well the answer to
that is because that's where it happened
it isn't as if he suddenly invented the
story and decided he would set it in the
room and ER it's based on a very long
poem
which he had been front of him she wrote
and where he actually borrowed a number
of phrases from as he was writing so my
feeling is that Shakespeare must have
had in this grand house of his in Newton
new place of study whether a rather a
lot of books and that he probably
persuaded his fellow actors that they
ought to let him go for a number of
weeks every year perhaps in Lent when
the services were closed he would come
up to Stratford I think and get on with
the serious job of writing which was so
important to the attorney other members
of the company he might have been there
four hundred years ago today well yes
yes were there I mean are there no rice
fields around London some people
speculate that Shakespeare may have had
affairs yeah while he was away from home
well we do make of that well we do have
an early anecdote which says that he did
actually in in 1600 and won a London law
student called John Manningham who
incidentally has a lovely no touching
description of the power than the news
of the death of Queen Elizabeth was
received which of course is being
commemorated the four hundred
anniversary of which is commemorated now
with a great exhibition here
at the Folger Shakespeare Library but
John many who also picked up a story
circulating in learns of the society
which suggests that Shakespeare had a
reputation as there's a lecture and a
wit the story and it exists in a
manuscript in London the story goes like
this upon a time when Richard Burbage he
was the greatest actor in Shakespeare's
company when Richard Burbage played
Richard the third
there was a citizen that means a female
citizens wife grew so far in liking with
him that before she went from the play
she appointed him to come that night
unto her by the name of Richard the
third they had an assignation he was to
come and say Richard the thirds at the
door Shakespeare overhearing their
conclusion went before was entertained
and at his game ere Burbage came their
message being brought that Richard the
third was at the door Shakespeare caused
return to be made at William the
Conqueror was before Richard exists in
two separate versions it may it does
sound a bit too good to be true perhaps
it may be a bit of POC reform but it
does suggest that Shakespeare may have
taken advantage of his spare time in
London to entertain himself with with
citizens wives thinking about lovers
knots of one kind or another yes the
endpapers to your book you like so many
wax seals appear before us can you tell
us about where that seal comes from yes
well it's a fascinating story
this red scarlet
wax seal and that's you was specially
made for me at the birthplace trust from
a ring which we we have at the trust and
which we exhibited in a permanent
exhibition and it's a ring that was
found in Stratford in the early
eighteenth nineteenth century the the
the great painter Benjamin Hayden heard
about this and wrote a letter
extraordinary letter to his friend John
Keats the poet Keats in which he wrote
with great excitement I shall certainly
go mad he said in a field at
stratford-upon-avon
to Shakespeare they found a gold ring
and see you with the initial thus WS and
the true lovers knot between if this is
not Shakespeare who is it that true love
us not as sure as you breathe and that
he was the first of beings the seal of
belong to him O Lord he was really
excited he was excitable man was
Benjamin he replied to that with
understandable but kindly skepticism but
I'm more inclined to believe it than
many other people have been the find was
made as I think I could do for my quote
by a labourers wife in a field next to
the churchyard oddly a man named William
Shakespeare was working in the field at
the time the ring was nearly black with
rust and although wheeler who was a
local antiquarian bought it on the day
it was found mrs. Martin had already had
time to have it as he says unnecessarily
immersed in aqua Fortis to ascertain and
prove the metal a tassel workmen Smith
shop which consequently restored its
original color but regrettably destroyed
what might have been useful evidence in
the Rings and crustacean and wheeler
tells us that he found no Stratfor daeun
of that period so likely to own such a
ring as Shakespeare but most
intriguingly I think he noted that no
seal is affixed to Shakespeare's will we
have Shakespeare's will it's in it's in
it's in the public record office in
London and he says that no seal was
affixed to Shakespeare's will but where
the Scrivener of the scribe who wrote
the will had written in witness whereof
i ice I have set here on to my hand and
seal the words and seal was struck out
as if Shakespeare had recently lost his
theory so that helps me to believe that
this is not madam is impossible this is
perhaps the only physical relic of
Shakespeare that we have but that we had
more would indeed is thinking about the
the afterlife and Shakespeare's
reputation since his death in 1660 you I
mean one of the things that a lot of
people would mention first of all and in
fact it's a growing industry is
it is the the old chestnut about did
Shakespeare write Shakespeare and the
authorship controversy now you do
address this in the book yeah in no
uncertain terms I wonder if you could
share some of that with us yes in my
career as a Shakespearean I very
frequently have been involved in
discussions sometimes slightly
acrimonious discussions with people who
think that Shakespeare it was written by
Marlowe or by the Earl of Oxford he's
the present favorite or by Francis Bacon
for example and this did this idea
didn't start actually until the 19th
century there's no questioning of
Shakespeare's authorship of the plays
until the middle of the nineteenth
century when a man called is a New York
lawyer Fred Colonel Joseph C heart he
found that the plays absolutely team
with the grossest impurities more gross
by far than can be found in any
contemporary dramatist
now you seen in a way he's trying to
protect shakes to his reputation because
he says the plays are full of dirty
jokes Bob said it was absolutely true
and that he therefore wished that the
place had been written by somebody else
that Shakespeare who was by now almost a
god figure had not actually been
responsible for these but he didn't
identify the original author and the
first extended attempt to suggest that
Francis Bacon may have written the plays
came in an article by a lady called
Delia bacon also American in 1856
convinced that the plays could not have
been written by one whom she conceived
off as an ignorant low-bred vulgar
country fellow who had never inhaled in
all his life one breath of that social
atmosphere that fiddles his plays
she thought it more like that they were
written by a committee in 1853 in fact
she raised funds for a visit to England
where she spent three years writing a
book on the subject she moved a
Stratford from London in 1856 she was
very sick at the time and she spent a
night in Holy Trinity Church where
Shakespeare is buried with a lantern and
with tools intending personally to dig
up Shakespeare to open the grave where
she hoped to find documents
that would confirm her theory as dawn
approached she gave up the idea that and
that she might have found in shakes to
his grave a little bit saying it wasn't
really me it was that fairly
preposterous I think anyhow her book was
published in in 1857 subsidized without
her knowledge by the novelist Nathaniel
Hawthorne who was consul in Liverpool at
the time it was not I feel well received
later that year she came to believe that
she was no longer Delia bacon but the
Holy Ghost and surrounded by Devils a
nephew managed to bring her home to
America where she died in us in an
asylum the following year but what she
had started has opened the floodgates
and very frequently indeed now people
still continue to raise this this corner
to suggest that the place were written
by somebody else I I write about this in
relation partly to the the great scholar
Sam Shoen Baum who of course lived in
Washington and worked here for much of
his life in his great book Shakespeare's
lives shown Baum devotes a hundred
ironical pages headed
deviations to attempts to prove that the
works are written by over fifty
candidates ranging from Francis Bacon
through Queen Elizabeth the first to
Daniel Defoe in recent years the most
vociferous and long-winded claims have
been made on behalf of Marlowe Jake's
with contemporary dramatist and Edward
de Vere the 17th Earl of Oxford Marlowe
is particularly implausible his death in
1593 very early in the career of William
Shakespeare is one of the best
documented events in English literary
history and that he was a very
flamboyant character too and the
suggestion that this flamboyant
character could have lived on for about
twenty-five years at least not only
concealing his own authorship for
everybody in the busy world of the
theatre but also leaving no traces of
his continued existence while obligingly
allowing an actor called William
Shakespeare to take credit for an
unexampled string of masterpieces is
surely absolutely obviously absurd the
Earl of Oxford died in 1614
and that and the idea that he wrote the
plays requires him to have left about a
dozen plays ready to be filtered through
to the to the acting company the king's
men as opportunity arose
he too was modest enough to allow the
man from Stratford the credit for his
entire body of work for the theater as
well as his poems while also concealing
his authorship form from all his
contemporaries and these and similar
theories are heavily Pub publicized over
the past 15 years or so I've often been
called on in public debating places
ranging from a day-long mock trial in
the Middle Temple where I was
cross-examined by an eminent QC Queen's
Counsel now Lord Alexander I'm glad to
say that Shakespeare won the day ranging
from that to a debated in the Theatre
Royal baths were the claims of bacon
Marlow and Oxford were aired you began
to get the feelings it didn't really
matter who wrote the plays as long as it
wasn't Shakespeare
now all these cases rely on conspiracy
theory the beliefs that those who
they're all those who knew the truth
conspired together to conceal it from
their contemporaries while obligingly
leaving tiny cryptic clues to be
discovered hundreds of years later which
of course means that by their very
nature these theories can neither be
proved nor disproved and only only a
couple of weeks ago I was lecturing in
bath at the baths military first of all
and at the very first question that I
had after I give my lecture came up from
somebody who stood up and and and and
said you know that he put forward his
idea that the Earl of Oxford had written
show you can't get away from it but I'm
afraid I do become a little impatient
with it sometimes when a lot of a lot of
material is written after 1604 as you
say forgery is something quite different
yes we don't have the manuscripts that
we would like to have of Shakespeare's
plays
we don't have letters that he wrote to
Anne Hathaway
you mention it which is richly suggested
earlier but Samuel island is a key
figure in this whole industry of wanting
to have
experience manuscripts yes you're right
about these forgeries yourselves are a
important phenomenon yes in the later
part of the 18th century there was a man
called Samuel Ireland who had a son
called William Henry and he was a
congenital liar was William Henry
Ireland was something of an engraver and
he decided that his father was
interested in Shakespeare and would very
much like to have had a lot of
Shakespearean documents the son very
kindly obliged by creating a lot of
Shakespeare documents he was employed in
a lawyer's office where he had access to
spare leaves of parchment and old papers
and also to ancient seals and before
long he was able to present his
astonished and grateful father with a
wonderful stream of papers including
business documents about the globe
letters to Shakespeare from Queen
Elizabeth and the Earl of Southampton a
love letter complete with a lock of hair
and verses written by Shakespeare to
what he called an hath or away an
appendix to Shakespeare's will making
amends for the bequest to the widow of
the second best bed a new manuscript of
King Lear improved by the emission of
bawdy passages again this desire to
protect Shakespeare's reputation by
removing any suggestion that he might
have had a dirty mind and and also
manuscript extracts from Hamlet an
absolutely ridiculous portrait of
Shakespeare which again i reproduce in
the book and also he offered his father
two previously unknown Shakespeare plays
one called Vortigern and one called
Henry the second he explained they'd all
come from a great chest in the house of
a wealthy young man of his acquaintance
who preferred to remain anonymous and he
and from February 1795 the boy's father
Samuel invited various luminaries to
inspect the finds in his home among
those who paid homage was James Boswell
biographer of dr. Johnson who fell to
his knees kissed the relics and declared
that he could now die happy he did three
months later well though that that whole
story was exploded within it within a
year or so but for a while it did
it commanded relief curiously thinking
about the influence of Shakespeare's had
on other artists I know much of the book
addresses music which is you know one of
your own passions and interests and you
write about the composer Berlioz yes
Berlioz the great French composer whose
50s I think is being celebrated now was
a competitor who was became absolutely
passionate about Shakespeare it's very
odd because he didn't understand a word
of English but he was influenced partly
by falling in love with an actress
called Harriet's Harriet Smithson when
she went to Paris with with Charles
Kemble and she she played it she played
Ophelia in Hamlet and Berlioz is quite
knocked out very her the impression made
on my hearty rights and the mine on my
heart and mind by her extraordinary
talent they her dramatic genius was
equaled only by the havoc wrought in me
by the poet she so knew tably
interpreted Shakespeare coming upon me
unawares struck me like a thunderbolt as
I said this was the more surprising and
that Berlioz knew no word of English he
haunted the theatre obsessively
throughout the winter eager for glimpses
of Harriet dreaming of marriage to the
woman he'd not yet met and he continued
to suffer love for her after her return
to England for a while he seemed to have
recovered and he became engaged to a
pianist but she jilted him and in 1832
Harriet the actress happened to go to a
concert of Bella's his music in Paris
which she couldn't fail to recognize
herself as the idealized being
celebrated in his great symphony
fantastique
at last they met and after many vices
issued including a Romeo like suicide
attempt by Berlioz in which he took an
overdose of opium in Harriet's presence
then vomited for two hours they married
is vital and they married in October
1833 she died relatively young in 1854
and 10 years later
Berlioz records in his wonderful
memoirs ten years later in a bizarre
episode which could only have happened
to Berlioz her body had to be exhumed
for reburial after the rotting coffin
had been wrenched open the gravedigger
watched by Berlioz and I quote picked up
the head already parted from the body
the unguarded withered hairless head of
poor Ophelia and placed it in a new
coffin ready for it at the edge of the
grave before the remains were reburied
next to those of barely as his second
wife in spite of all that Berlioz read
some of the very greatest music ever
inspired by Shakespeare's great dramatic
Symphony Romeo and Juliet for example
his opera bear Tristan Benedict and he
was a rather Robin composer I mean these
great funeral march for the last scene
of Hamlet quite a long piece which
includes a chorus who have nothing at
all to sing except the word Oh every so
often and many other great composers of
course have been inspired by Shakespeare
on things above all perhaps of Verdi
with the great operas the Otello and and
for stuff particularly and more recently
Benjamin Britten in his also great opera
based on the Midsummer Night's Dream
there are more parodic influences as
well and in fact one of the way that
ways of getting out of this seriousness
of that we in which some people approach
Shakespeare is to mock him yeah and is
to send up the plays yeah and you write
very interestingly about Shakespeare in
parody in the book as well in the
Victorian period particularly it was
very common for writers to put on
onstage
erotic complete full-length versions of
Shakespeare's plays which which which
were parodies of the plays and it's I
first got interested in these when I
discovered that while Henry Irving was
playing Hamlet at I see it a very famous
production of performance his
performance was actually being made fun
of by another actor in a in a parodic
version of the play at one of the minor
theaters and this became a little genre
of its own the the the parodic versions
of Shakespeare often parodying not only
Shakespeare himself but parodying
their rather grandeur
productions of his plays which were
common in the Victorian theatre I think
the best of those actually is perhaps
well there's a rather good one by
William brough called Perdita or the
Royal milkmaid in which for example the
discussion sorry it parodies past
passages even from other plays sometimes
and the discussion between Leontes and
Camillo in in in The Winter's Tale is
based on my best and Leontes ends with
oh never shall Sun that fine day see we
made him welcome he's himself made free
I bid him come to court but on my life I
little thought he'd come to court my
wife and then later with the great comic
writer WS Gilbert of Gilbert and
Sullivan Fame wrote a burlesque or of of
Hamlet called race and Crimson
Guildenstern not risen Cranston
Gunderson are dead but just Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern which again was a
response to Henry Irving his
performances and the in that burlesque
of philia gives other direct for parody
of of criticism about shakes but you
know about Hamlet you know Hamlet is
often it's often said that Hamlet having
it's real problem was delay couldn't
make up his mind and also that he wasn't
really mad or the people argue about
whether he was mad or not so in the in
the in the play she says some men who'd
that he's the same as far of all saying
men something he's really saying but
shamming mad some that he's really mad
but shamming saying something that he
will be mad some that he was some that
he couldn't be but on the whole as far
as I can make out what they mean the
favorite theory is somewhat like this
Hamlet is idiotically saying with lucid
intervals of lunacy in fact there's a
few comic illustrations in the book as
well be nice to find bye bye max
Beerbohm
yeah max lubbers is one of my favorite
writers and artists of course he did
wonderful
parodic drawings there's a charming one
based which I'm reproduced based on the
the idea that bacon wrote Shakespeare of
bacon slipping and the manuscript of
Hamlet - Shakespeare but bibim also did
a drawing based on a story about the
writer Frank Harris Frank Harris was an
editor newspaper editor a very obsessive
character loud mouthed womanizer
miscellaneous right of the early 19th
century and Oscar Wilde for example
wrote about him Frank Harris is upstairs
he wrote in the letter of 1899 thinking
about Shakespeare at the top of his
voice
if Harris had known Shakespeare he said
he would have done anything for him once
during a lunch at the cafe Royale he
declared homosexuality no I know nothing
of the joys of homosexuality my friend
Oscar could no doubt tell you all about
that but I must say if Shakespeare asked
me I would have had to submit and this
incident inspired all the racier
cartoons of max Beerbohm in which he
portrays a trembling Shakespeare behind
a naked Frank Harris ha Jake's be
clearly horrified at the thought Stanley
I wonder if you could let us to share
with us how far this influence has come
up to the moment and where Shakespeare's
reputation is right here and now years
horse it's growing it's changing it's
developing all the time but you you do
end the book with a wonderful peroration
of Shakespeare over the last 50 years
right up until the last few months
really within the last year's in
Stratford well as I said the book could
only have a provisional ending because
he obviously things are still going on
have gone on since I submitted the
manuscript to the to the to the
publisher but it is true that research
and interest in Shakespeare carries on
in a great many different ways at the
present
time as I say in the book for example
tourists who find it visit who find it
difficult to visit Stratford in the
United Kingdom may more easily visit
Stratford Ontario with swans imported
from its namesake or the theme park
village in Japan which includes replicas
of Shakespeare's birthplace Anne
Hathaway's cottage mary arden's house or
the full-size replica of Anne Hathaway's
cottage packed with 16th century
antiques in Victoria British Columbia we
spent the last weekend as it happens at
the Shakespeare Conference wherever they
go they'll have no trouble in picking up
Shakespeare related souvenirs ranging
from the tasteful through the tacky to
the obscene models of the birthplace in
Anne Hathaway's cottage tea towels
bottle stoppers pencils erasers fridge
magnets thimbles candles chocolate bars
keyrings even at the Vermont Festival
Shakespeare condoms all the dorms with
choice images and quotations I think
perhaps the competition has found the
right quotation to go once as I was
walking along Henley Street where
Shakespeare's birthplace is I heard a
little boys sake say look mummy William
Shakespeare and his mother replied oh
yes his head's on the tea bag a more
expensive relic of course was the copy
of the first folio sold in New York a
couple of years ago for 4 million 166
216 pounds I think was less interested
in by composers in Shakespeare nowadays
rather sadly but of course the scholars
go on writing him writing about him a
great deal and dotty nurses are just as
common as they used to be a Sicilian
teacher claimed for example that
Shakespeare was born in Messina as
Michelangelo Florio Crowell and sir
Shakespeare South African scientists
proposed that Shakespeare smoked
cannabis on the basis of
misinterpretation of a phrase to keep
invention in a noted weed
in sonnet 76 along with the discovery
that pipes found in Stratford showed
traces of the drug a German scholar
claimed to have found evidence that
Elizabeth Vernon who married the Earl of
Southampton was the Dark Lady of the
sonnets and that Shakespeare had an
illegitimate daughter by her and as the
daughter Penelope went on to marry the
second barren spinster this would mean
that the Princes William and Harry are
directly descended from Shakespeare
performances the plays go on of course
in a very great many very different ways
they were given that Stratford they
continued to be given all the time at
Stratford England of course in astro fat
on Terry Oh a couple of years ago at the
globe Vanessa Redgrave played Prospero
in The Tempest cross that sort of
casting of women in male male roles has
become quite commonly will it would
happen again the entire female company
would pay at the globe this year of
doing Shakespeare
many different adaptations in many
different languages are made in Indian
in South Africa in Japan for example in
fact it appears that Japan presented
more performances of Shakespeare in one
form or another in 2001 than any other
English than any English speaking
company any other non-english speaking
country so in lapland a six meter high
replica of the globe hewn out of blocks
of ice now offers performances of
Shakespeare to winter audiences I spoke
to somebody who'd been to see Hamlet
they said luckily during his passage in
our and in 2001 the Norwegian town of
Bergen witnessed a production of Macbeth
given on a tabletop in which macbeth was
represented by a tomato duncan by a can
of tomato puree and other leading
characters by a can of lager and a
thermos flask as a friend of mine
quipped tomato and tomato well thank you
for sharing those jewels of the book
some of the jewels of the book with us
family I'm going to open the floor for
questions now if anyone has a question
for professor Wells
yeah Shakespeare no any language other
than English yes the question is whether
Shakespeare knew any language other than
English he must have known a good deal
of French there's a whole scene in Henry
v written in French a short scene
between the the Princess Elizabeth and
her tutor as it were her lady lady but
also there's good reason to believe that
Shakespeare could read Italian at least
because the story of a fellow is based
on the story which had not been
translated into English in Shakespeare's
time it's by Gerald H in T oh and he
could only have got it to the best of
our belief by by reading it in the
original Italian and of course he knew
Latin he he went to a Grammar School in
Stratford and the word very words
Grammar School indicate the sort of
education you got at a Grammar School in
Shakespeare's time you got taught Latin
you got taught in Latin you had to speak
Latin from the age of about seven you
got talked Latin literature and Latin
rhetoric it was about all you you were
taught he and it's no doubt that at that
grammar school he achieved he acquired
his familiarity with the great writers
of classical antiquity above all of it
he was particularly fond of of its most
of metamorphosis which actually brings
onstage in the play of Titus Andronicus
and from though the two we acquired
there in the training in rhetoric which
is so evident especially in his earlier
plays where you can see the rhetoric
coming so yes I I think one of the
fallacies is often propagated by those
people who believe that Shakespeare was
not Shakespeare one of the fallacies is
that the place couldn't have been
written our two learned to have been
written by somebody educated and
strengthened that is just nonsense it's
been conclusively shown that the act
that the standard grammar school
curriculum in Shakespeare's time was
perfectly adequate to explain the the
the learning such as it is that lies
behind Shakespeare's plays any more
questions
yes just
so you spoke earlier about how the book
is moving away from a sort of academic
look at Shakespeare do you feel that in
the UK especially Shakespeare's
suffering because it has become over
academic academia sighs sorry as
demonstrated by the fact that the
English a level system no longer make
Shakespeare compulsory for its pupils no
I think I think if you if you no longer
make Shakespeare well I think to make
Shakespeare compulsory for children
schools runs the risk of making
Shakespeare boring you know it depends
of course on how you're taught and I say
I was lucky I had a very good teacher
and there are many very good teachers at
the present time but I think a very
healthy thing that's happened in England
is that increasingly school teachers and
also academics to have have realised
that Shakespeare's place is in the
theatre and that you can't really
understand or enjoy the place and the
plays were written to be enjoy it wasn't
to be taught you can't really enjoy them
without seeing them performed at the
very least imagining their impacts in
performance so nowadays far more
teachers take Shakespeare to see
productions of the plays that then was
the case in the past I was a school
teacher myself forms and I mr. the story
I remember about that that he goes
against what I've said perhaps I took a
group of schoolchildren to see Henry the
fourth part walk in Southampton in the
Theatre Royal Southampton on a Saturday
afternoon the theatre had hardly any
people in it except us it was a very big
theatre and I realized too late this is
of course it was cup final day and
everybody was at home watching or
hearing hearing about the cup final on
television and the production starred an
actor who had once been a very good
actor
but he was now rather old and he was
wearing a deaf aid now the thought of a
Falstaff with death Aid was not
particularly plausible and on that
occasion actually I wished I hadn't
taken them because it's what it is it
most important if you're taking them
that
should be saying a good inspiring
production but of course nowadays it's
far easy to do that through films
through videos and films films
particularly the films by Kenneth
Bramlett I think and also others like
Baz Luhrmann's Romeo + Juliet for
example have created new waves of
interest and make the place more
accessible to two people including young
people who might find them rather boring
simply to read them
yes it is I think it depends how it
works I think I mean I don't think
Shakespeare should always be done in a
sort of heritage style after all the
plays were written contemporarily in a
contemporary manner in their own day
they were performed in modern dress
Julius Caesar Coriolanus in
Shakespeare's day would have been worn
partly in his recent costumes and I
think some of the very best productions
that I've seen have been either in
modern dress productions or sometimes in
neutral costumes it were costume which
is of no specific place or time but it
does depend on how it was I have no set
ideas when I go to the theatre I don't
say I'm not going to see the play
because I've heard it isn't in doublet
and hose there any basis to believe that
the sonnets are autobiographical well
this is a subject I discuss a
considerable length in the book yes I
think there is people argue a good deal
there are these 156 sonnets and you're
5454 sorry to have my former pupil with
me there are these 154 sonnets which
most of which are apparently addressed
to a young man and there are the final
group of the sonnets which are addressed
to or concern a love affair with a young
woman now it's possible that Shakespeare
invented the whole thing that this is a
fictional scenario created in order just
to to make to make poetry as it were but
the other possibility of course is that
they derive from his own personal
biography that they reflect his
reflected genuine love for a young man
yeah the lovely young man is never
explicitly stated to be a sexual love on
the other hand it is a very passionate
and very intense love and then they also
reflect his love for the dark lady in
the dark woman
whoo and it's a very weird love that he
has for her because he writes about her
in contemptuous terms quite often and
clearly despises himself for his
emotional entanglement with her and
another sort of thread running through
the soreness is the idea that there was
a rival who was also a poet and that the
the woman had a relationship with both
the poet Shakespeare and the the young
man with whom Shakespeare was on one of
the Oh men with whom Shakespeare was in
love
I personally am inclined to believe they
are autobiographical to a large extent
partly because they don't make coherent
sense as a fictional narrative but I
think Paul somewhat disagree with me
about that you spoke about the the
authorship controversy as something that
really derived from the United States
and the 19th I seem to recall that there
was another American influence on
Shakespeare that concerned Stratford in
the 1840s the house where Shakespeare
was born on him on the market and an
American by the name of Phineas T Barnum
announced his intention to buy it and
did nothing to discourage speculation
that what he intended to do was
disassemble it ship it across the
Atlantic reassemble it on wheels and
carted around the American frontier as
part of the great what would become the
greatest show on earth
I would like to ask a little bit about
the what happened of course is that a
group of narrow minded Englishmen banded
together and outbid Barnum at auction
and thereby kept the house where it was
and assured that Stratford would become
perhaps the world's greatest theme park
we don't I do think it was ignorance but
I I would like to ask Paul who is
director of education at the Shakespeare
Birthplace trust to talk a bit about
some of the programs that the trust runs
for educational purposes yes yes thanks
to him one of the narrow-minded
men who were on that original committee
was Charles Dickens who helped purchase
the the birthplace and to keep it in
Stratford well now of course Stratford
is committed the birthplace Trust is
committed to sharing the knowledge of
Shakespeare throughout the world and as
director of Education I'm very aware of
the remit and we have international
university courses that come to
Stratford we do work with local schools
national schools we do work with
lifelong learners and actually one of
the programs which which relates to your
book Stanley is taking place this August
it's called Shakespeare's Britain today
and we're teaming up with another
independent charity called Cumberland
Lodge and Cumberland Lodge is based in
the great park of Royal Windsor
it's right next door to the Royal Lodge
of Windsor where the Queen Mother spent
a lot of her her life and where she died
recently and common law is very palatial
beautiful building and they run study
programs that's what they're committed
to in fact it was a gift of the Queen
Mother - this body comes and lodge just
after the Second World War to promote
international communities to come
together and an tarantal erm and we're
doing a program at the beginning of
August which looks at Shakespeare's
influence on modern times how modern
institutions such as the law such as the
church such as the way we understand
modern writing and can be reflected on
to Shakespeare's own time and those
similar institutions looking at the
difference differences between them so
well if anybody's interested it's the
first two weeks of August we can come
and Lodge the Royal Great Park of
Windsor and then a week after being the
neighbor of royalty to be the neighbor
of genius in distracted upon Avon based
the Shakespeare Birthplace trust well be
looking more at the Shakespearean
influences in Shakespeare's time so
that's that's part of what we do so yeah
I think it is important to stress that
the Shakespeare Birthplace trust is not
simply a tourist organizer
which you know just milks people but by
putting them through the houses and
making them buy things in the gift shop
is little party
that's that maybe the public front of
the birthplace trust it's a non profit
making organization it has no it has no
public subsidy and it's an organization
which does a good deal behind the scenes
educationally we have a museums
department we have a lie I'm chairman of
this organization so I speak with some
feeling our library and the records
office we're in fact half of the
original documents relating to
Shakespeare are preserved that documents
such as the only letter addressed to
shakes when we have just one letter
written to Shakespeare in his lifetime
for example and the records of his
purchases of land and so on so the trust
is much more than its simple public
front of tourism it's also a culture on
an educational institution to indeed use
the tourism which which funds mainly
everything else I mean it was a shakers
birthplace and Anne Hathaway's cottage
we we would be able to do all the other
educational work that we that we do do
which we we feel very committed to and
we which is all passionate about and the
record will not show that anyone made
any remarks about a theme park well I
think we've come to the end of our
allotted time I want to thank once again
Tony and Sue Brenton for hosting this
lovely event amanda downs of the british
embassy for all that she did to make it
happen
Stanley Wells in Paul Edmondson for
giving us a delightful hour of
Shakespeare jana and all of you for
being such a wonderful audience thank
you very much
Stanley Wells is chairman of the
Shakespeare Birthplace trust in England
Shakespeare for all time is published by
Oxford University Press on the web at oh
you P - usa.org